la humillación pública para quienes
atentan en contra de la política de
'cero cobit del país
estos son cuatro hombres vestidos con
trajes de bioseguridad esposados y
fuertemente custodiados los acusan de
llevar ilegalmente a extranjeros a las
fronteras de china que han estado
prácticamente cerradas desde marzo de
2020 la policía local les colgó del
cuello carteles con su nombre y foto y
los hizo desfilar por la ciudad los
medios estatales criticaron estas
acciones asegurando que están prohibidas
desde 1980 pero la pandemia ha hecho que
las medidas draconianas sean algo común
en china xian ha visto como sus 13
millones de habitantes han sido
encerrados durante una semana los
hogares reciben comida de manos del
estado cada tres días algo que es
insuficiente para muchos que han tenido
que recurrir a las redes sociales para
buscar ayuda
[Aplausos]
qué es lo que tienes que comer me muero
de hambre
no tengo nada nada las autoridades
locales admitieron que la entrega de
alimentos se ha visto afectada por
restricciones mientras priorizan las
pruebas masivas 160.000 personas se
movilizaron y se construyó un enorme
centro de pruebas nuevo que han quedado
tenemos la capacidad de aquí para
procesar 2 millones de pruebas pcr todos
los días con nuestro propio método ya
que todo el resultado un número de casos
diarios que es sólo una fracción de lo
que se puede encontrar en otros países
el jueves sólo 224 personas dieron
positivo en el territorio continental
cuando se trata del comité en china
parecería que el fin justifica los
medios